[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  sir  [Music]  pumpkin is a trip where credit stated  business school  that means it's owned all three big  quality international labels here's a  target shot for each one of them  [Music]  check it out  [Music]  and second one in a row  [Music]  [Music]  around the plants hit the cup let's go  [Music]  honking offers a two years master's  program in English you can study  marketing finance economics management  accounting and commercial law  [Music]  now let's check out the classrooms  [Music]  let's make me around  [Music]  nice trickshot  [Music]  and this is the hunka business love this  restart of Hispanic nurse  [Music]  you text evocative for sponsoring this  we now we had a lot of fun filming here  Thailand is a great place to start it is  safe concert with a lot of friendly  people if you are interested at starting  at honking make sure to check out the  link in the description to find more  information about the school until next  time  [Music]